-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
According to a new report,
top Democrats
are starting to worry
that President Biden
will run for re-election
in 2024,
specifically this top Democrat.
[ As Biden ] "Oh, do I have to?"
[ Laughter ]
After the house committee
investigating
the Capitol attack
showed video testimony last week
of Ivanka Trump saying
that she did not believe
her father's claims
of election fraud,
former President Trump
said that she,
"Checked out of
election results."
Though to be fair, that's just
what people used to do
after an election was over.
[ Laughter ]
The house committee
investigating the Capitol attack
today held
its second public hearing.
They weren't going to,
but then Rudy Giuliani said,
"Make it a double."
[ Laughter ]
Fox News today also aired
coverage
of the House January 6th
committee's second hearing.
Said Fox News viewers,
"Bam, I'm on TV!"
[ Laughter ]
"Remember that thing?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Police in Idaho on Saturday
arrested 31 members
of the white supremacist group
Patriot Front
after they were discovered
inside of a U-Haul truck
near an LGBTQ Pride event.
And based on the photo,
I assume
Patriot Front is
a style of khakis?
[ Laughter ]
You got flat front,
pleated front,
and Patriot Front.
And, uh, those
only come in extra small.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you thought they were
packed into that U-Haul.
[ Laughter ]
The Labor Department
announced on Friday
that inflation has hit
a new 40-year high.
You will now pay the same amount
for a banana
at the grocery store
as you used to pay for a banana
at an airport Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
"Forbes" magazine
announced last week
that golfer Tiger Woods is
officially a billionaire,
leaving him no choice
but to start a company
to launch him into space.
[ Laughter ]
The Tony awards
were held last night,
and "A Strange Loop"
won Best Musical.
It's the musical adaptation
of my penis.
No!
[ Laughter ]
I'm not doing that joke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Ikea in Norway
has launched
an online baby-name generator
based on its product line.
They just figured you should
have something from Ikea
that lasts more than a year.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.